after lunch and we have a very exciting
talk on the power of positivity by Kunal
maraha with rusby and Bill Fairman
thanks
my name is kanal I'm a graduate student
at University of Chicago and I'll be
talking about qma and Q May plus you
know what the power of positivity can do
for this complexity class as a preprint
we put out
um last month with Roost Bay and my
advisor bill and it's also inspired by a
work by Fernando Geronimo in Peru that
appeared in stock this year
what if the outline it will be two parts
of the talk first I'll kind of give an
introduction to this qma plus this new
complexity class and try to motivate
some of the context that led to this and
then I'll walk you through you know the
key steps in the proof
so the context here is really about qma
and qma2 and the question here revolves
around you know the power of unentangled
proofs so if qmas are you know Quantum
version of NP qma2 is kind of this
fundamentally Quantum thing where the
proofs have you know a special form
so to review qma is a set of decision
problems that in the yes case there's
some Quantum proof that's input to a bqp
machine and you accept with at least
probability C
and in the no case no matter what
Quantum proof I get
you know if you input in a bqp machine
it'll accept with it most probability s
there's a standard definition of qma
qma2 has a slight uh Wrinkle in this
where it's also a set of decision
problems
but in the yes case you know you have
this state that is separable over let's
say half the qubits
so the the quantum proof is unentangled
across this bipartition
but in the no case and this is actually
really important in the no case your
only resistant against States
against Quantum proofs that are
unentangled also on this bipartition
so in qma2 a qma2 protocol might
actually
get broken if you were allowed to send
Quantum proofs that were entangled and
so this kind of symmetric promise
symmetric restrictions actually makes
the class much trickier to study
and I'll and I'll explain you know how
that motivates this
so let's talk a little bit about some
facts about qma and qma2 so the first
thing you might ask is you know does the
C and S matter so if C and S are at
least inverse polynomial apart you can
amplify the gap
and so for qma you can do this with
parallel repetition how does this work
you repeat the verifier circuit many
times
and in the yes case you're going to get
many copies of the right Quantum proof
and in the no case even though they
could be entangled you can't you know
cheat
for qma2 this doesn't actually work but
there's another thing you can do called
the product test by Hero montenaro and
this allows you to amplify the Gap in
qma2
so the CNS once they're inverse
polynomial apart it doesn't seem to
matter how big they are
another thing you might want to know
about is upper bounds so both of these
classes can be simulated in NX not a
germanistic exponential time
so how can you see this the bqp machine
can be simulated in X and the witness
the quantum proof can be guessed
non-deterministically
so for qmate you can do better you know
you can in fact put it in P space using
a semi-definite program and in fact you
know even tighter bounds are known PP
and a0pp
but for qma2 we actually don't know any
other stronger upper bound
you know and and the question is you
know why can't we do better can we do
better was the question I think for a
long time and now maybe the question is
why can't we do better maybe actually
this qma2 is super powerful maybe it's
in fact it's equal to NX
option so far
so the you know this motivated uh you
know studies of NP protocols in qma2 and
other things that I think inspired
Geronimo to define a class called qma
plus okay and let me walk you through
the definition of qma Plus
so q a plus again is a set of decision
problems where in the yes case my
Quantum proof has an additional promise
where it has to have non-negative
amplitudes okay so what do I mean here I
mean that take the computational basis
you know take the state vector and I
mean all the amplitudes are real and
non-negative
okay and again in the no case
I'm only going to be resistant against
states of this type
so Quantum proofs that are non-negative
amplitudes
so you can similarly Define qma2 as the
same kind of cumulate two plus as the
same kind of setup where the proofs are
unentangled and they have non-negative
amplitudes
so now you're kind of asking about the
power of this non-negativity
yeah yeah so the motivation I'll explain
the motivation for why this so this they
made this modification to the complexity
class that allowed them to prove
something and I'll explain what that is
okay
this is a definition clear
so you might say okay maybe I've seen a
class like this before you know there's
a paper that studies sqma qma with
subset States and here you restrict a
subset state is a state that's uniform
over some subset of the computational
basis States
and you could say oh you know there's
this sqma which the quantum proof has to
be a subset state
but actually this restriction is only in
the completeness it's only in the yes
case
and so it's kind of for this reason
that sqma is equal to qma
because in the no case of sqma they're
resistant against all Quantum proofs
whereas in these kind of other types of
complexity classes I've been showing you
the Restriction is two-sided we're only
resistant against a certain class of
quantum groups yeah
they have the optimal witness can be a
substrate
the option witness yeah no case there's
a trick that whether an on Sila if zero
then you accept would work too far or
something like that and then there was
an optimal condom witness that sort of
Subspace goodness accepts
yeah so and I'll talk probably if you
have two-sided restrictions okay then
there is some Gap where they're equal
yeah so it's independent
I think a lesson here that I want to
component is like if you have this
promise symmetric restriction you can
actually increase the power you can make
the class A lot more powerful because
you're kind of restricting Merlin's
ability to cheat
okay so so we might try to ask some of
these same questions about qma plus and
qma2 plus
so
we can say okay what about Gap
amplification do those CNS parameters
matter and it turns out they might you
know the standard thing you would do is
parallel repetition you would repeat a
verifier circuit many times
and the main thing that breaks down here
is so in the yes case it works in the
yes case you can send me many copies but
in the no case Merlin can kind of use
the fact that you're making partial
measurements to eventually send you
states that have complex phases in them
it's kind of like a graphic here is that
you know if we repeat this verifier
circuit many times we might start with a
state with non-negative amplitudes but
if we make a partial measurement let's
say over the first third of the qubits
we may not have a state that has
non-negative amplitudes anymore
and this can be you know used to to to
kind of get a better score than what you
would hope uh a cheating Merlin would do
okay so so this what this says is this
the technique for parallel repetition to
get Gap amplification just doesn't work
and this this by the way also happens
with qma too so it doesn't mean that
there's no way to Gap amplify just that
this technique this naive technique
won't work
foreign
so the other thing you might try is you
know maybe we can upper bound this class
okay and so maybe we can you know write
down a semi-definite program that
optimizes over the the best quantum
proof and it turns out this also fails
and the reason this fails is that if
you're trying to optimize Over States
with non-negative amplitudes this turns
into optimizing over the co-positive
cone and this if you have polynomial
size matrices you can compute
Independence numbers of graphs and so on
these are NP hard so for exponential
size matrices it's not clear it's any
less hard than all of NX
so this technique also can't can't work
to give you an upper bound
so co-positive cone is sort of the cone
you would write down if I want to
optimize over the best
the best quantum uh proof where all the
entries and the proof are non-negative
so I guess it's a name that that it
found so when we were looking at
literature on this we found that this
this object had been studied before and
it was they called it the co-positive
gun
yeah it's been study outside
I I mean what what threw me off here
thinking about this is that you can in
polynomial time optimize overall
non-negative density matrices right and
for very very small system sizes like
size four actually they're the same but
this object is slightly different yeah
okay
so do you mind asking me so how powerful
is this plus what is the plus giving you
and I would like to say that actually
you know from one lens the plus is not
giving you a lot of power
and what what can you say so this is
observed by Geronimo and Wu every state
PSI has a one-quarter overlap with a
state with non-negative amplitudes
okay how can I see it I'll just walk you
through it
I take a state I take its real part and
imaginary part
take the part that's bigger let's say
it's real now take the real State now
split the positive components and the
negative components take whichever is
bigger now I have a state with
non-negative amplitudes
it has one quarter overlap so what that
means is you can turn a qma plus
protocol with a big enough Gap into a
qma protocol
and the same thing for qma2 plus you can
turn it into a qma2 protocol
so it means that there are these
constants CNS where qma plus equals qma
and qma2 plus equals qma2
so in some ways you know if you choose
CNS big enough
these classes are like cousins you know
there's the there's a qma class and
there's qma plus there's qma2 and
there's qma2 Plus
you mean if you choose c big enough and
S small enough right yeah so I'm sorry
if I choose the Gap big enough thanks
just adaptive enough to get some Gap put
here in it but then are you good well
you can amplify qma
can you
but you're saying you can you can
amplify it while keeping those
restrictions
so so if if CNS are different enough
then you can for for Q a plus and ask
him a plus you can number five
that that's what this also implies yeah
yeah
the efficient way of creating your
original state that you can also create
actually that state that has one thought
of overlap with that state efficient
efficiently
eat some kind of surface
so I don't know if you need to do it
efficiently so the proof of how you can
do this is that if I have a protocol
let's say CS 0.9 and S is 0.1
then I can make S I can turn it into a
qma c in 4S protocol
because now every state that I that I
send through is going you know at least
one quarter of the state is going to
fail
Ure no it's not important it's just an
analysis technique that's correct
it's in fact the same technique that's
in the reload all paper the study of
subsequently
to reduce C Prime and S Prime are they
constants yes
okay so but what was surprising and I
think this is what motivated this class
in the beginning was actually for qma2
plus there are some other constant CNS
you can choose that's equal to NX
so okay so so what does that mean so on
the one hand qma2 plus is equal to qma2
for some Gap
and on the other hand qma2 plus is equal
to NX for a different Gap
and so if only you can add you know if
this Gap doesn't really matter if you
can Gap amplify
then actually that would imply that qma2
equals NX
and I think this is a this was a really
exciting result because it gave you a
new opportunity to study qma too
so our work that came out last month
kind of says something that complicates
the picture
in fact the same thing is true for qma
plus there are some constants you can
choose CNS
or qma plus is equal to NX
and what we do is we take the Geronimo
and we'll proof we make several several
modifications and we show the same thing
works even if you only have one copy
so now we have a class qma plus
that interpolates you know if you change
this Gap C minus s or you take the ratio
C over s but in constants goes from qma
all the way to NX
and qma is contained an X and even in
smaller classes so unless qma equals NX
which is extremely unlikely
um there's there's no way you can have
Gap amplification of qma Plus
so this kind of complicates the picture
of Gap amplification in this class
so I want to you know you have one slide
on how do you interpret these results
you know there's kind of q a and qma2
and these cousin classes qma plus and
qma2 plus
and and the first thing you might say is
maybe actually that all the power is in
this plus you know the plus is what's
giving the power it's not the two it's
actually you know the Plus
but I mean it's not clear right because
you know at some constants it's equal
the classes are equal
and so at least if you're going to use
positivity in this qma2 plus to study
qma2 and NX whatever Gap amplification
technique you use cannot work for qma
Plus
so you're going to have to be a lot more
clever about using an entanglement and
positivity to get Gap amplification if
it exists at all
questions
okay so from here
um I'll go through the proof outline I
think we'll have time to go through it
and um
all kind of separated into two parts
first I'm going to put NP in qma plus
with a logarithmic size proof
the reason I do this is pedagogical it's
so we can talk about polynomial
everything is polynomial sized I don't
worry about succinctness I don't worry
about exponentials that's the main
reason but it turns out everything can
scale to NX
and I'll say a couple of words about how
you do that at the end
yep
thank you
so I don't know uh for qma plus equals
qma you can use
um 0.8.2 or anything above that 0.8 1.19
for qma plus equals NX I know they're
constant I don't know what the constants
are yeah
good question
okay so okay so how are we going to
start we're going to choose a problem
that's MP hard okay so we're going to
use the obvious thing we're going to use
the CSP
a constraint satisfaction problem we'll
say there's n variables we'll say
there's a bounded alphabet
bounded alphabet size and kind of Q
uniform constraints Q is also bounded
and we'll basically ask is if this
instance is fully satisfiable or not
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use we're going to use
the PCP theorem we're going to say
actually we're going to ask a stronger
question which is actually still just NP
complete which is is the completeness
one or sorry can you satisfy all the
constraints or can you only satisfy half
of them
it turns out that this Gap as long as
it's constant doesn't matter as long as
it's constant the proof goes through
so Q is like the number of variables
that is involved in a constraint
so for maximum cut it's two but for
others it's bigger
the plan is to solve this in qma plus
with a logarithmic size proof
so I want to give you kind of a picture
here this helps me understand what
positivity is doing you know on the left
we have kind of two wave functions that
have positive and negative amplitudes
and they can cancel you know you kind of
are adding these two wave functions and
they and they disappear
we're on on the right side everything is
non-negative
and so you can't cancel out amplitudes
and so in a way like this positivity
thing is is kind of taking out the
destructive interference it prevents
things from canceling out when you might
want them to so it removes a kind of a
way that Merlin can cheat
if you know the state is is has positive
amp uh non-negative amplitudes then you
can't use it to create destructive
interference
I'm sorry
so it was asked as you know is this a
reasonable picture because if I change
the basis then this may not be true
so what I'll say is these results hold
as long as you know you can have you
know a basis that you can efficiently
get to the computational basis
so if your non-negative amplitudes in
some basis that's
you know is um you can prepare
from that basis into the computational
basis then this works
okay so so what we're going to do is
we're going to require Merlin
to send a certain type of quantum proof
so we know that the proof is
non-negative amplitudes and we're going
to ask basically for a stronger property
and I think the big idea here from
Geronimo Wu is that if you look at the
overlap in a hadamard basis with the
zeroth Fourier component it's actually
proportional to the L1 Norm of the
vector
so if you have a projector in the
hadamar basis and you look only at that
zeroth component
then you're going to accept a state with
non-negative amplitudes
relative to its L1 Norm relative to kind
of its its Spark It's measured in this
in this uh this measure sorry
and so I will say this is like kind of
the only use of positivity in both
papers it's like to do this something at
the bottom of all of the positivity
constraints is this object
and we're going to use this object in
ways to guarantee a stronger kind of
uh state that Merlin is sending us but
this is the kind of the key point
I mean I thought if the key Point as
being that with non-negative States uh
if you have two orthogonal ones then
they must have disjoint supports is that
just a special case of this fact
non-negative States
yeah if they're orthogonal then they
have disjoint supports right or at least
like men Geronimo and we talked about
like that was what they presented
yeah I would say this is kind of like a
special case yeah the same thing yeah
I'm not sure I would say underneath all
of this is kind of measuring in the
hadamar basis gets you a measure of L1
isn't this sort of saying this this this
would give you a
that your superposition is spread out
yes yes exactly
okay
so I'll walk you through how Geronimo Wu
used this assumption and I'll kind of
present the key point at least from our
perspective
is first notice that qma2 plus and qma K
plus are equal with some constant Gap
you know not all gaps of course but for
some constants and and
you can see this by walking through some
of the Harold montenaro steps not all of
the steps work but some of them do that
gives you this
so you can assume now that you have many
copies of a state with non-negative
amplitudes
and then we'll what we'll do is we'll
project this pi plus operator on each
copy and we'll count the fraction that
accepts and this gives us an estimate of
the L1 Norm
because this operator accepts
proportional to the L1 Norm so it gives
us an estimate
and so what we can then do is we can ask
for states that are close to an L1 Norm
that I want
so if Arthur has a particular you know
sparsity in mind then
they can ask for it by making sure the
states are close
okay and you can use this to get
stronger properties like subset States
and so on but this is kind of the main
point is you can estimate the L1 Norm
so with one copy of the state we can't
do that right with one copy we can only
measure one thing or at least partially
measure
so what we're going to do is something
slightly different we're going to
separate the registers into two parts
we'll say the questions which have you
know log n qubits or they'll have poly
and qubits in the in the NX protocol and
the answers and it's very important the
answers are only constantly many qubits
okay
what we'll do is we'll choose one of two
tests we'll choose either a test the pi
plus over the whole input
so we're kind of encouraging the state
to be as dense as possible
and the second test we'll choose is kind
of the complement of the pi plus
operator but only over the second
register
so this second test if you had a general
State you can pass it with probability
one but if you have a state with
non-negative amplitudes you can't
actually pass this the probability one
the reason is you're accepting kind of
proportional so the to the L1 Norm which
can't go down Beyond kind of just one
answer one component in the answer
register
so in the second point I have some some
projectors
and the projector I can I can you know
there are states that succeed the
projector with probability one
but if I promise that my state is
non-negative amplitudes
then I I claim that I cannot pass this
with optimal property with probability
one
and the test is checking whether this
this expectation is high enough yeah I
just measure this yeah the probability
of acceptance
so you can say like the you know the
second test what it's doing is it's
trying to minimize the number of answers
so for a given question you know it
doesn't really matter how many questions
you have but for a given question in the
answer register I only want there to be
one answer if I have two answers then
I'm going to fail with a with more
probability
so so choosing uh tests like this
choosing
um you know the probabilities correctly
if I want the state to be as dense as
possible and yet that you know spread
out as possible and at the same time I
want the state to be you know have only
one answer per question
gives me states of this form which I'll
call a rigid form
and the form is kind of uniform over the
questions and one answer per question
so what we're doing is now we've
guaranteed a state of this form
and if you're far away from this form
you're going to fail these tests with a
constant bigger
then States like this will fail
okay so this isn't this isn't as general
as getting a Target L1 Norm or something
like that but it turns out this is all
you need
to finish uh to to kind of finish up the
solving the NP problem
other questions about this
and you're doing these two tests
separately
that's right so with some probability P1
I do the first probability P2 I didn't
say
but you want to be very big
very precise on your answers on each one
separate no I only need to do it once
yeah because I do it once and then I see
the probability I accept
and what I'll see is the maximum
probability I'll accept is will be
states of this form
and if you have it okay then get a
cradle between between how spread out
yeah so this comes down to the key point
is that the answers are only constantly
so once you have more answers perfect
question you start failing much more
often
this is yeah that's a it's a good point
to make sure the trade
it works kind of the way we got it to
work was kind of only if these answers
were constantly
so so maybe one picture that might help
uh is
um presented an idea from Brian O'Gorman
which is you have test one
and test two and we're going to look at
the kind of the success rate of this
test and so they were orthogonal
operators so you can't pass them you
can't the sum of passing them can't be
more than one
but if you have states that are
non-negative amplitudes it kind of
blocks off some amount of passing tests
too
and so the rigid States we're looking
for are at this circled point and if we
choose the probabilities of test one and
test two appropriately
the best thing you can do is give me
States at that at that Circle
so how are we going to use this power so
I'm going to make the questions the
constraints so that's pretty important
I'm going to make the questions
constraints and I'll make the answers
the assignments of the associated
variables so every
sub problem or yeah so we're going to
solve some CSP let's say it's three sub
yeah
so if it's three set then the
constraints will have R constraints some
poly and constraints and I'll have you
know three variable assignments per
constraint
okay
and so in in the completeness case in
the yes case there's going to be some
satisfying assignment so I can always
set the variables so that
um every constraint is satisfied
but it's important notice that the first
register are constraints indexes from
one to R
and the second register the answer is
kind of a list of variables
and I might use a variable more than
once in fact I probably will
and so in the yes case I can always
write down some satisfying assignment
so with some probability we're going to
test this rigid form you know using
those tests I gave you and with some
other probability we're going to test
the constraints
so J is the index of the constraint
let's say
yeah so let's say I have n variables and
R constraints or RS on poly n
ope Okay so
testing for the rigid form means testing
both at the superposition is uniform and
also that like there's exactly you know
that there are no phases well well there
couldn't be phases anyway because of the
non-negativity that's right right so so
it's really just like a uniformity test
that's right in a way you know if you're
familiar with these NP protocols this
was the kind of thing is you you need
some uniformity uniform object yeah yeah
and do you need one cup just one copy of
Psy or multiple cup just one cup yeah
so with multiple copies you can get a
measure of sparsity and you can use that
to get sepsis dates and that gives you
that correct form when Geronimo
in our in our approach those two tests
those kind of pi plus or kind of pi plus
over the second
register that gives you this one okay
but with one copy you get some constant
completeness cell in this gap which
might be a really really tiny one that's
perfect
can you get a better one if you have
multiple copies of Psych
it's not clear not clear yeah
so okay so how do we test these
constraints so from here we're going to
assume that the states are rigid because
you know if they weren't rigid the other
parts of my protocol would have found
that
and actually for rigid States checking
the constraints is quite easy I'll
measure in the computational basis
and I'll get out some J and F of J J is
the index of a constraint F of J are the
you know the Q variable values
associated with that constraint
and I'll check it I can compute it
classically or if you want I can compute
this in superposition so to speak
but you know in soundness Merlin can
cheat you know
I could send for the same variable on
different constraints I could send
different you know values that make the
constraints pass
so we kind of have need to add one more
test
to make sure that the variable
assignments are consistent
so this consistency test is kind of the
most technical part but it's also the
part that's been done before
but let me describe what this
consistency test is about
we're going to try to construct a set of
unitaries
let's say constantly many unitaries such
that if you're honest if you have a
consistent assignment then the state is
invariant under the action of the
unitary so PSI is equal to U PSI
F of J and then make sure that your
superposition is
that's not
that you don't have you know F of J is
now a variable but it's some some
variable right so you you make sure that
your superposition on the first register
doesn't include both uh you know that
variable negative as well so
um are you suggesting changing the
question and answers to be you know
right I'm sorry whatever that's not just
one thing
was focused on one there is one
constraint so that's that's an important
decision so so if the J is a constraint
F of J is let's say Q different variable
values
um but it was it was focused on you know
your your uh only one in super position
right right right so so if you were to
measure F of J
um so so you know if I think of it as as
a superposition of a day so those are
the
things
and then each one you've picked out
exactly one variable
right that's what the second read isn't
it so it picks up the whole list so
there's conspicuous constant Sigma is
constant so I can actually include the
whole list of variables and that can be
my answer
so let's say three set over binary
instances there's gonna you know eight
strings I can send and I will choose one
of the eight strings
and this is important so I think um
there's a you know there are ways to
kind of use and code just variable and
values yeah but then you have a hard
time actually checking that the
constraint is satisfied
all right so you're you're saying you
actually choose to if you get the
assignment all the all the variables
check it if you if you just take one
yeah and if you just pick one
contributed because so wouldn't there be
this so there's there seems to be this
simple test but maybe it doesn't work
where you just
they just just measure the variable name
and now look to see if the if the
superposition
register
is um you know its support is only on
one you know on unnegated
right so that would give you a
a test maybe it doesn't work maybe it's
a probabilities
so it turns out for some kinds of
constraints you actually can do this
yeah like for Unique game constraints
you can do this but in general
so to recap we're gonna we test for
rigidity then we're going to check the
constraints but you know there's this
other cheating possibility which is
you're sending me an inconsistent
assignments because I'm sending the
whole list of variables good
so so the goal here is to be to
construct some set of unitaries you want
a UD
such that if you're honest if you have a
consistent assignment then
size and variant
but if you're inconsistent in some way
then PSI is not kind of it's kind of
detectively far from UK on site for some
k
okay so suppose we have these unitaries
and I'll tell you how to construct them
afterwards
if we had these unitaries
then what we do is we choose a random K
from one to D and then we'd run the
hadamar test on PSI and UK on PSI you
can think of the hadamard test like a
swap test but we're kind of controlling
on the unitary
foreign
so this is kind of this is the what
we're going to do but I haven't told you
how we're going to make these unitaries
so how do you make those unitaries
sorry go ahead
identical variables
yeah that's this is the right idea yeah
good okay so we're going to basically
build a graph
we're going to build a graph using uh
the pre-processing set of Daenerys peace
proof and the PCP theorem
but we're going to turn each variable
into a cluster
we're going to take every variable into
a set of vertices one vertex per
constraint
and then once we have the cluster
we're going to add an expander graph
within the cluster
so I'll give you an illustration of how
this works so here we have let's say one
variable I is in black and it's attached
to five constraints it's involved in
five constraints
program create five vertices they're an
orange
and then we're going to add an expanded
graph that's in green
okay
so we're going to do this for all
variables
so G is going to be the union of n
different expanded graphs
but note that it has R times Q vertices
R is the number of constraints and Q is
the uniformity
so we're going to create this graph
so recall that this rigid state is of of
the form like this you know for uniform
over the constraints and we have the
variable list of the involved variables
sorry the values of those variables
it's going to be convenient to separate
the variables out
and what we would like is kind of to
have every variable assignment on its
own you know on its own
so maybe uniform over the constraints
uniform over the indexes of the
constraints
and then kind of like each entry of the
variable
because now if you look at this now we
have R times Q
you know options in the first register
and we have kind of one one option for
each vertex of this graph
foreign
and I'll just say one thing that this
map from going from PSI to Phi we can
actually do this
um there's a little bit of kind of it's
a little tricky but I'm happy to talk
more about it offline
so suppose now we have this Phi this
kind of uniform over the superposition
uniform over the vertices of the graph
with some variable assignment according
to that value
what we're going to do is we're going to
decompose this graph into permutations
we can take a deregular graph compose it
into deep permutations
so if we had this D regular graph where
D is two you can kind of take the half
edges and draw two different
permutations
what we'll do is we'll we'll set the
unitary to be kind of the action of this
permutation over that first part over
the J and the index of the constraint of
the variable involved in j
and now that we've done this the kind of
the key idea is that if you have an
honest assignment
you know
all the vertices are only connecting
variables so if you have an honest
assignment
or a consistent one
then the value shouldn't change as you
go from one part of the variable to
another part of the variable
so if you stay within the cluster the
value should be the same so you're kind
of invariant and this expansion property
the fact that we use expanded graphs
kind of amplifies the cheating that's
like the intuitive picture
so so the protocol is is
this this is the protocol we test for
rigidity we check the constraints and we
make sure the assignments are consistent
questions
[Music]
yeah yeah so it'll scale with the amount
that you're off it'll like if you're off
by just one value you're not going to
catch that so much
because you're off by a lot of values if
you're far from kind of being consistent
then you'll fail with some concept
and what is it and how is the suspension
property help you learn that
living
yeah so it's kind of the way I think I
think about it the qualitative way I
think about it is that what expansion is
doing is it's kind of you can't just
you know be cheating on a few variables
that are kind of far away from the rest
of the graph
so if you cheat on a few parts of this
cluster it's super connected to the rest
of the cluster and so you're going to
find it in these other edges
so it kind of amplifies the fact that
you've been cheating yeah so I guess if
my customers how much so so I was
imagining here we've just a big one
place for instance
yeah it'll get Amplified by a factor
let's say two or something like that it
doesn't need to be a very good expander
just uh some consonant
I'm missing maybe there might be two
Notions of expansion being used one is
the expander here the second one is the
expandering American PCP
if you started off with a TCP version
I see so if you clarify when in this
last comment which which expansion
you're talking about I see good thanks
so this expansion I'm talking about is
in this this last part this consistency
test where I built this new graph so
this is after I've already pcp'd the
problem
so my input now is this already PCP
problem that has a completeness one
soundness one half
and now eventually I'm going to build
this graph
that
I'm going to add kind of another set of
expander graphs in it
my confusion I guess here is Q is
supposed to be a constant rate
if you just pick the cycle
spectral gap of a con like a Cycles like
well it'll be like 1 over Q squared
so I don't really see where the
expansion computers yeah that's a good
question so I should say that the size
of the cluster we don't actually know
what the size of the cluster is it could
be it could be polynomially large or an
NX exponentially large the size of the
cluster is the number of constraints a
variable is involved in
so it may not be a constant
because
that's true
because you do the same Cloud thing
I think it's it's possible that so the
reason you need something like
consistency is because you need a way to
check the constraint and to make sure
you're not you know cheating and
consistency at the same time
and so the way that I'm asking for the
quantum state is I'm asking for each
constraint and the values going with it
I guess if I was asking something else
then I wouldn't need to do this
I guess it's like a PCP in the PCP but
this is what we need to do to get the
right to get a constant Gap
when the pre-processing steps contains
so I mean the part that we need is this
amplification of cheating
so what this does is now that we have
expanded graphs everywhere it kind of
just a couple things one now the graph
is regular
so that's really important now that the
graph is regular we can work with it
with let's say a constant you know
d-regular DSM constant
but the expansion also helps with
cheating that kind of either you've been
cheating on the constraints the original
constraints which are hyper edges and
kind of in this model or are you
cheating on the expander editors
so this is actually you're right this is
kind of how we get a regular graph from
uh
not necessarily a regular excuse me
like you may put this like really
simplified because they have good
coffees and they can do some other tests
yep that's a good question so Q May 2
plus in that paper they actually do need
this for the NX apart
they study a different problem they
study a problem that has unique that's a
unique game problem okay and in the
unique game problem you can do something
as Umesh suggested which is like you
only list a variable and its value and
you can still check the constraints the
problem is now when you scale to NX
there's not a strong enough PCP known
for NX that is also a unique game so
they switch back to this General CSP and
then they have to do something like this
so this technique here by the way this
technique is you know used by the nerve
but also used by geronimum group
I'll just say a few words about
um how do you scale this up to NX
um the reason I present it in this way
is close to talking about unique games
is because now the only thing we have to
do is worry about succinctness
so okay so we need an NX part problem
now so we're going to have capital N be
2 to the little n
and the instance now has to be succinct
there has to be let's say a polycized
circuit that that
um represents the instance and the
question you know is this instance fully
satisfiable or not
so again by the PCP theorem so even for
constant size alphabet and constant
uniformity we can still get a constant
Gap you know either we satisfy all the
constraints or only half of them
So the plan now is we're going to put
this in qma plus with a polynomially
size proof
so I will say that the NP protocol just
almost works
the main thing we need to do is we need
to ensure that Arthur's protocol is
efficient
and the only issues come up in this
consistency test
in particular there's kind of three big
issues the expanders could be
exponentially large
that's because a variable could be
involved in exponentially many
constraints
there could be exponentially many
expanders because those degrees could be
of different sizes
and the adjacency list could also be
exponentially large
so kind of the problem is all about just
representing the CSP instance and being
able to Traverse the CSP instance
yes that's correct yeah so so now we've
moved to NX hard problem to
exponentially many constraints
exponentially many variables
and so there are solutions for these
which drawn on and will also address
um
for exponentially large expanders we can
construct them in poly log size of the
graph
um we can also decompose them into
permutations and poly log size in the
graph
for exponentially many expanders we can
use kind of the strongly uniform PCP so
a PCP would with or the number of
constraints a variable is involved in
is one of constantly many options
so now we only have to draw constantly
many expanders
and the third question about adjacency
lists being exponentially large we can
also use a doubly explicit PCP
and this this kind of strong property of
the PCP allows us to Traverse the
variable indices and variables and
constraints in poly log size of the
graph of time
so once you do that everything else
works this is these are the only
adjustments you have to make
so I think I'll leave you with a couple
of conclusions that we came from this
work and you know
the the first thing is that these
promised symmetric classes are really
powerful they can you know both this
qma2 plus and qma plus can reach NX
but this the promise Gap seems to really
matter like in qma Plus in particular in
constants you can get from qma to NX
and like one question you could ask is
like what are the right constants are
there constants that give you kind of
like a phase transition like you know is
there a constant where it's convenience
tax
is that a different constant than NX and
so on so forth we don't know any of
these um we don't know anymore
from the plus to a non-plus
99 weight on positive
right right you can ask the weaker
conditions than plus you know like is
there is there you know if you add some
complex phases how much complex space
comes in yeah
do we know that qma with real amplitudes
is equivalent to q a with complex
implicants yes
the second thing is really back to the
story of kame 2 which is you know this
human two plus was stuck you know
invented to study human tube
and suppose you know you still want to
use this positivity to study qma2
but just know that any technique that's
going to amplify the promise Gap can't
work for qma OnePlus
and so you're going to have to be clever
about using you know unentanglement and
positive amplitudes together
um it just presents A new challenge in
this direction
kind of you know the big question is
what is special about qma2 Plus
that qma plus doesn't have you know what
what does it have that qma plus doesn't
have and you know if at all
so thanks
[Applause]
uh questions for canal
to just coming back to this which is
about um whether you can allow a few
negatives right so so it looks like the
way the positivity is being used is to
make sure that the superposition is well
spread up
a month basis if you if you do that for
a general it will stay if you would uh
you know let's say let's say we only had
real amplitudes but then then you'll be
checking you know if the all zeros
coefficient
um
with either highly positive or highly
negative
thought that you have very few negative
entries when that's zero almost
everything you need
to be originally to be the problem right
because there's where you have minus
this could help
yeah it's possible
so I think you know one you know the
core of the questions you know like how
strong is this plus promise you know can
you weaken this promising
maybe it's either too strong or not
there I'm not sure
okay if there are no more questions uh
we resume at 3 30.
[Applause]